Paris province c'est bien Paris province
le caviar le blini voilà
elle est pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais remercier les Algériens pour
tous les messages de soutien que j'ai
reçu suite à ma blague sur
l'hospitalisation de son Excellence
Abdelaziz de la bouteflik
non ça fait chaud au coeur tous ces
encouragements type espèce de connard
[__] Tintin raciste et autres douceurs
verbales bien sûr j'aimerais présenter
mes excuses c'était de l'ironie c'était
c'était l'urne il est clair que si
Bouteflika s'est fait soigner en France
c'est pas parce qu'il y a pas d'hôpitaux
adapté en Algérie non c'était juste pour
donner à la maladie une chance de s'en
sortir
c'est tout
bon à part ça je sens que vous êtes
encore à sticker la tête avec la baisse
des charges sociales
c'est extraordinaire mais arrêtez de le
prendre au sérieux ah il est une love là
c'est pas c'est Woodstock dans sa tête
mardi gras dans son slip il faut cesser
la question le pack de responsabilité
va-t-il faire baisser le chômage
évidemment
comme le pack du mpudi fait trembler la
Chine c'est couru
franchement vous avez rien d'autre à
faire vous occupez de ces gens qui sont
dans une activité
comment avoir un gouvernement en
mouvement si sa principale obsession
concerne les inactifs
au lieu de se préoccuper de ces gens qui
ont la chance de s'emmerder à la maison
on ferait mieux de s'occuper de ceux qui
font exactement la même chose mais au
travail
non mais de toute façon si on baigne
dans la morosité c'est parce que on
passe notre temps à se focaliser sur des
sujets qui nous dépriment alors qu'il y
a plein de sujets sexy en ce moment il y
a l'IVG le tanazi le découpage des
régions c'est génial ça comme tu aimes
le découpage des régions c'est tellement
excitant bon c'est un peu simple c'est
vrai quoi enfin il suffit de faire deux
trucs de région zone libre zone occupée
non
non pardon non non Paris province c'est
bien Paris province le caviar le blini
voilà
alors il y a toutes ces bonnes nouvelles
mais sinon à l'Elysée en ce moment c'est
c'est plus compliqué il y a cette prise
d'otage qui continue après human bombe
Hollande bombasse enfin le mec il est à
vous quoi il s'ouvre déjà du syndrome de
Stockholm pour pas la vexer il a
installé son ravisseur à la lanterne
comme ça
alors que tout allait super bien pour
lui tu vois enfin closer sortait de
nouvelles photos gagner Hollande au
States qui sort du show Justin Bieber
puis ensuite dîner en tête à tête au
Starbucks bataille de cheesecake enfin
c'était trop chou quoi tu vois
moi j'espère qu'il va se pointer avec
guerrier aux USA ça sera au moins
l'occasion de faire un peu le mariole
avec Obama ça va venir dire alors
baraque toujours avec ta meuf
[Applaudissements]
bon à part ça mon bourg a dit ouais le
scooter ce serait bien qu'il soit
français c'est pas évident c'est bien
qu'au début d'une relation c'est
toujours un peu délicat de faire le coup
de la panne alors que tu es pas encore
arrivé chez la meuf tu vois
en tout cas manifestement le prochain
combat humanitaire de Valéry sera pas
les enfants de Centrafrique mais les
desperetta au swive de Santa Barbara
c'est l'air un peu plus
il y a quand même bizarre volonté c'est
le seul mec qui a l'air d'aller mieux
après une paparazade
puis vous devez vous réjouir vous c'est
bon ça pour volant
son coming out social-démocrate là le
truc qu'il cru qui lui cru le Trotski St
enragé du Bourget qui sent canaille en
douce dans les backroom de Loris quoi
c'est dingue mais bon la question qui se
pose en fait on en discute qu'est-ce
qu'un social-démocrate c'est un homme
qui pense qu'on peut faire avancer la
France à partir d'un consensus entre les
syndicats le peuple la fonction publique
et le patronat
c'est un mec qui a débarqué hier gare de
Lyon pour la première fois de sa vie
c'est
l'idiot des Ardennes
mais vous laissez pas faire non mais
c'est vrai qu'il faut il faut y aller un
peu c'est vrai il faut avancer quoi je
veux dire autrefois les anarchistes ils
savaient provoquer la Première Guerre
mondiale aujourd'hui c'est à peine si ça
foute le bordel dans une vente privée
pour dire
[Applaudissements]
politique alors Sarkozy là il a vraiment
le mojo avec les vieilles c'est
Bernadette Chirac qui annonce son retour
en 2017 c'est non mais lui il a un truc
c'est le Diane fossé de la gérontologie
ça c'est mamie dans les brumes c'est
quand même un peu la honte t'imagines ta
grand-mère qui twitte sur la réformation
des Sex Pistols
je sais pas
amour alors on a supprimé le mot
détresse comme raison de l'avortement
c'est cool on va enfin pouvoir avorter
pour le fun
j'imagine bien la nympho qui va venir la
consultation vous êtes enceinte ou et en
détresse ah non non moi je vais super
bien mais pour une fois dans ma vie
j'aimerais bien savoir ce que ça fait de
se faire aspirer plutôt que de se faire
carcheriser
la finesse toujours c'est important
international
Damas est accusé d'avoir massacré à
l'échelle industrielle apparemment on a
retrouvé du cheval dans les charniers
sécurité routière il paraît que sur
diminue la vitesse de 90 à 80 km/h les
accidents de la route peuvent sauver 400
vies supplémentaires par an 400
dire est-ce qu'on a vraiment les moyens
d'accueillir tous ces gens
pour finir télévision parce que c'est
quand même le lieu où tout se fait alors
Sublet en place Taddeï c'est cool il
reste plus qu'à remplacer Yves Calvi par
Thierry Beccaro et on est bon
plus besoin d'aller à l'école
procès Zahia ça s'est passé cette
semaine alors les prévenus n'étaient pas
là pour des raisons professionnelles tu
parles ils avaient surtout peur de
retomber amoureux
et la bonne nouvelle il y en a une elle
frappe son compagnon parce que ce
dernier a joui trop vite lors d'une
fellation
enfin moi je dis ça c'est juste pour
assurer ma famille je vais mieux
alors pas belle la vie et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de inarritube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu